bonjour et merci de nous avoir rejoints
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale une émission de 13
minutes en ce jour férié du premier mai
et on commence tout de suite avec
l'actualité la semaine 60
000 70 c'est le nombre de chômeurs dans
les Yvelines à la fin du mois de mars ce
sont 650 personnes de plus inscrites en
catégorie A dans 100 activités par
rapport à fin février une hausse de 1,1%
alors que le nombre de chômeurs s'est
stabilisé en France sur un an il est
temps de 5,8% contre 4,1% pour la
moyenne nationale même constat cependant
dans tout l'hexagone on compte moins de
jeunes au chômage mais beaucoup plus de
seniors sur un an le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi de moins de 25 ans à
diminuer de 1,7% dans le département
alors que c'est lui des plus de 50 ans a
grimper de 12,5%
. la société d'édition versaillesse
Cocktail Games sort un nouveau jeu de
société perlimpinpin un jeu déjà
existant à l'étranger dont ils ont
acheté la licence et vous allez le voir
les partenariats entre les sociétés du
secteur vont bien plus loin des
entreprises concurrentes et alliées
c'est possible des images de Yolaine
Torres
je vais jouer le 3 City
des princesses voilà le but du nouveau
jeu de Cocktail Games perlimpinpin la
société d'édition de jeux de société
Versailles poursuit son essor et propose
un jeu américain un carton outre
atlantique qui nous emmène dans un monde
de princesse et de chevaliers au
programme je de mémoire d'addition et de
tactiques un jeu créé par une enfant de
6 ans et départ ses parents le jeune
initial s'appelait sleeping Queens voilà
édité par un éditeur qui s'appelle game
Wright donc on a repris les droits
francophones européens du jeu et on a
décidé de changer son nom qui s'appelle
perlimpinpin c'était des rois et des
reines dans le jeu et là maintenant
c'est les princes et les princesses
changements de nom et changement de
design le tout imaginé pour plaire aussi
bien aux garçons qu'aux filles comme
l'illustrateur a été briefé par la
petite fille qui voulait qu'elle fasse
les cartes comme elles le pensait les
cartes sont très enfantines et du coup
on a gardé tout ce concept là on a juste
égayé le packaging
pour que ça saute plus aux yeux et pour
que ça fasse plus féerique Cocktail
Games espère en vendre de 30 à 20 000
exemplaires par an ce n'est pas la
première fois que la société achète une
licence à l'Américain game white même si
les adaptations de jeux déjà existant à
l'étranger ne représentent qu'un quart
de leur offre cette raison proche de
travailler sur une bonne licence parce
qu'il y a des gens un jeu qui a une
expérience marcher voilà après ça nous
amuse aussi beaucoup de voilà de signer
des jeux de les tester de les mettre sur
le marché de prendre un risque
commercial qui existe aussi dans le
cadre d'une licence mais qui est moins
en fait il y a moins de bruit par le
fait qu'il y a eu un passé commercial
sur le jeu déjà au delà des licence les
sociétés d'édition à l'image de Cocktail
Games salir régulièrement pour co-éditer
des jeux et apporter leur savoir-faire
spécifique croiser leurs compétences on
est dans un secteur qui est assez sain
si vous voulez qui est concurrentiel
mais où chacun a des lignes éditoriales
je dirais plutôt complémentaires tous
les acteurs c'est un petit secteur
professionnel on doit être une vingtaine
distribution nationale et donc on fait
plus en fait des collaborations ensemble
ce qu'on appelle des coéditions c'est à
dire que c'est un partage de compétences
de risque financier et éventuellement de
profit parce que il y en a pas toujours
en fait c'est qu'une concurrence
acharnée où on se tient dans les pattes
Mathieu par exemple la coïté trois jeux
avec Emmanuel le dirigeant de la société
Monster Games plus porté sur les jeux de
société asiatiques ensemble ils se sont
lancés dans l'aventure en Corée du Sud
et ont initié un partenariat avec un
distributeur local happy baobab ça
marche super bien notre distributeur
était très heureux de distribuer ces
produits là qui était très nouveau pour
le marché et comme on en est de plus en
plus de produits de plus en plus de
nouveautés à un moment on s'est assis
autour une table on a discuté et on
s'est dit bah ça sert à rien qu'on soit
à la fois éditeur qui est un
distributeur de votre côté qu'on divise
des frais comme ça donc on a décidé de
le mois dernier de devenir une série une
quantité donc voilà donc maintenant on
peut dire que les jeux mon cocktail ont
un distributeur qui nous appartient en
Corée
ils sont les seuls étrangers sur ce
marché et ça marche car dans le pays le
système éducatif mise sur les jeux de
société pour l’apprentissage des jeunes
et le marché devrait s'élargir encore
aujourd'hui ça a changé c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a toujours ce jeu marché
éducatif mais il y a de plus en plus de
place pour les vrais jeux famille entre
amis grand public on n'est pas encore
sur un marché gamer mais sur les jeux
vraiment un grand public comme Mathieu
fait énormément et le marché c'est
énormément ouvert en France c'est les
jeux de société représente 10,4% d'un
marché du jouet qui pèse 3,1 milliard
d'euros
le groupe Mercedes Benz a célébré
vendredi dernier la pause symbolique de
l'étoile emblème de la marque sur les
toits de son nouveau siège social à
Montigny une installation saluée par le
maire Michel legier et nous vous
président de l'agglomération qui faisait
face à son prédécesseur Robert cas
d'Albert il prononçait ce jour-là son
dernier discours en tant que président
de la casquille le bâtiment affiche
quelques innovations environnementales
il filtre notamment les ondes le Star
Center comme il s'appelle représente
surtout un nouveau pôle automobile qui
rejoint sur le territoire l'un de ses
concurrents Renaud pour la direction du
groupe le but est de rassembler leurs
différents collaborateurs comme nous
l'expliquent le président de Mercedes
France
c'est le rassemblement c'est que le
rassemblement parce que aujourd'hui nous
sommes sur trois différents sites à
bailli à Rocquencourt et aussi à
Saint-Denis et finalement il y a
beaucoup de collaborateurs qui font le
chemin entre les trois différentes
entités et on a choisi de les mettre
tous ensemble parce que je pense qu'on
va beaucoup mieux pouvoir travailler
ensemble prenez par exemple quelqu'un
qui travaille pour les voitures
particulières et un autre qui travaille
pour le financement ils vont maintenant
devoir parcourir peut-être un escalier
et pas 15 km
nous vous parlions des derniers chiffres
du chômage tout à l'heure mes au-delà de
ces chiffres comment vit-on ce chômage
Albane de vous a connu une période sans
emploi pendant deux ans aujourd'hui elle
souhaite lancer une série humoristique
sur sur ces sujets pour changer le
regard des gens sur les chômeurs la
boîte de production et plus à rebasée à
Villepreux à choisi de soutenir ce
projet nous l'avons rencontré en
compagnie de sa productrice Virginie
guégu en dans son studio qui lui sert de
bureau un entretien réalisé avec
Jonathan wilmann et Romain russeini
recevez chez vous puisque vous lancez
une nouvelle série de quoi s'agit-il
voilà alors on espère on espère avec
Virginie guéduit donc lancé une série
sur la vie d'une petite chômeuse qui
résume et qui présente tous les côtés du
chômage personnel professionnel fictif
financiers etc avec un petit peu de
sourire en essayant des dramatiser un
petit peu la chose pourquoi finalement
aux amis cette idée
alors cette idée elle m'est venue tout
simplement parce que je suis passée par
là que ça n'a pas du tout été une
expérience facile à vivre et que je
trouvais qu'il était enfin en tout cas à
mes yeux qui manquait une image sociale
un peu positive du chômeur ou de la
chômeuse et
que c'est quand même quelque chose
aujourd'hui que beaucoup de personnes
sont amenées à traverser aujourd'hui le
chômage et que de rendre cette
expérience de vie un peu plus souriante
dédramatisé du moins en parler que ceux
qui la vivent en parlent je trouvais que
c'était important après des débuts en
journalisme puis en communication Albane
a connu deux ans de chômage c'est à ce
moment là qu'elle fait la rencontre de
Virginie guégu avec Albane se fait un
petit moment déjà qu'on se connaît on
s'était rencontré toutes les deux à un
cours de théâtre sur Paris durant lequel
on était en même temps au chômage
bizarrement et du coup parallèlement à
mon chômage moi j'ai créé une société de
production qui s'appelle epuard avec
Sébastien Onomo qui est le président de
la de la société et du coup Albane très
vite se rapproché de moi avec cette idée
de raconter une histoire autour d'une
chômeuse et d'en faire une série
humoristique et donc moi ça m'a beaucoup
plu j'avais très envie de développer ce
projet donc on a commencé à travailler
ensemble là-dessus au départ ça devait
être une série en réel donc on dit en
live avec des comédiens des acteurs et
malheureusement on a eu beaucoup de
difficultés à trouver des financements
on en a eu aucun donc du coup je
commençais à être un petit peu au bout
des solutions que je pouvais trouver
pour concrétiser ce projet d'où est venu
l'idée après d'Albane de créer un blog
de continuer à faire vivre son idée et
son personnage à travers des vignettes
qu'elle a dessiné elle-même très bien
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de vignettes
culte que j'aime beaucoup ce qui a
permis de garder une actualité sur
Agathe et sur le projet et nous de pas
s'essouffler sur le temps qui passait à
continuer à chercher une solution pour
développer la série et puis de faire
connaître aussi le personnage exactement
tout à fait de commencer à créer une
communauté autour
plus de réalisation de l'animation et du
pilote quoi et donc maintenant là on y
est on est vraiment en train de préparer
le pilote je pense que d'ici un mois
maximum il sera prêt et du coup on
pourra démarcher des diffuseurs et des
partenaires pour vendre la série elle
est encore plus loin avec les aventures
d'Agathe à 36 ans Albane est aujourd'hui
au taux entrepreneur dans le domaine de
la communication et de la photographie
mais l'écriture et le dessin pour
lesquels elle se passionne aujourd'hui
pourrait bien devenir son activité à
temps plein concrètement comment vous y
prenez pour monter cette série donc
Virginie a expliqué vous êtes entouré de
professionnels comment finalement vous
vous travaillez ensemble vous écrivez
d'un côté vous fait des croquis comment
ça se passe tout ce qui concerne
l'écriture du pilote donc les dialogues
le rythme qu'on veut lui donner etc
donc je travaille avec un corréalisateur
que m'a présenté que ma présentée
Virginie qui a un oeil justement sur le
rythme sur la mise en scène que je n'ai
pas forcément donc ça ça m'apprend
beaucoup
ensuite il y a le travail de l'animation
et ça bah écoutez ça prend forme de mes
dessins puis l'animateur on les met en
mouvement voilà et puis il y a aussi
tout un travail sur le son que je
découvre parce que en animation
effectivement on part un peu de rien
pour le son donc il y a tout de suite un
univers sonore à créer à définir et donc
ça c'est un gros travail avec
l'ingénieur son aussi Virginia est-ce
que vous avez du coup un regard
également sur l'écriture sur la trame
oui oui moi j'arrive à une étape clé
quand Albane et donc le réalisateur donc
quand le cours c'est Harry Bosino une
fois qu'ils sont mis d'accord à peu près
sur la version finale du pilote moi je
viens avec un regard plus neuf pour voir
si c'est cohérent si finalement l'effet
voulu fonctionne sur un regard neuf et
je peux apporter enfin demander quelques
modifications si je trouve qu'il y a un
problème de rythme qui a pas une
cohérence entre le dialogue et l'image
ou des choses comme ça mais je n'entrave
jamais la liberté de création nous des
auteurs ni d'Albanie du réalisateur mais
j'interviens quand même pour essayer de
préciser toujours un peu plus ce travail
de les mois de les pousser le plus loin
possible dans vers l'excellence quoi
pour pour parler directement on a de
l'ambition on s'engage pas donc du coup
il faut vraiment qu'on l'ait à toutes
les étapes et ça commence par la
première qui est l'écriture ensuite pour
le travail de préparation du pilote
d'animation c'est vrai que là Albane
elle a un gros travail à chaque fois
puisque du coup elle prépare une sorte
de storyboard assez poussée pour
vraiment que l'animateur ait un maximum
de matière entre les mains donc que ce
soit les décors les positionnements des
personnages pour que ce soit cohérent
avec l'écriture du pilote et ça c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu nouveau de
réfléchir en storyboard de réfléchir en
plan en séquence et de du coup avoir
pouvoir se projeter sur l'animation au
maximum avant de passer au travail avec
l'animateur quoi donc moi j'interviens
j'interviens à toutes les étapes mais
pas au début pour vraiment pas entraver
la création et la liberté de création de
chacun est-ce qu'on peut en savoir un
peu plus du coup sur l'histoire donc
c'est la vie d'une chose mais ça va
raconter
ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est
de partir sur Agathe qui devient
chômeuse et qui va apprendre ce que
c'est voilà c'est une découverte un
petit peu initiatique du chômage mais ce
qui me paraît aussi très important et je
pense que toutes les deux on a cette
priorité en tête c'est de faire un pont
entre l'histoire de cette chômeuse et
l'actualité enfin montrer que les
chômeurs ont droit d'avoir un regard sur
l'actualité de l'exprimer et voilà voilà
c'est tout
oui à l'image du plat pour le moment
merci Beaucoup de rien merci à vous
et on finit avec l'agenda je vous
propose de rendez-vous à la Cité des
Métiers à Trappes mardi prochain le 6
mai le groupement d'employeurs réseaux
78 vous propose de découvrir les métiers
de l'hôtellerie et de la restauration
les opportunités d'emplois les profils
recherchés alors pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas le réseau un
groupement d'employeurs pardon ce sont
des des employeurs qui proposent des
postes en temps partagé dans plusieurs
hôtels ou restaurants pour permettre aux
salariés d'avoir des CDI à temps plein
l'atelier débute à 14h inscrivez-vous
auprès de la Cité des Métiers et puis le
même jour vous pouvez également obtenir
des informations sur les formations
diplômantes si vous souhaitez échanger
de voie professionnelle mais également
acquérir de nouvelles compétences et
évoluer dans votre secteur le
Conservatoire national des arts et
métiers pourra répondre à vos questions
rendez-vous à 14 heures
et c'est la fin de ce fil écho je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine avec
Catherine zulato